me parece que ya estamos listos para
aprender qué sucede en las reacciones de
la fase oscura pero solo para recordarlo
rápidamente en la fase luminosa llegan
los botones y excitan a un electrón
hasta llegar a un alto nivel de energía
y luego conforme ese electrón va pasando
de molécula en molécula bajando su nivel
de energía y todo eso lo tenemos por acá
todo esto está sucediendo en el 'tie la
coi de dentro del cloroplasto ok de
hecho está sucediendo en la membrana del
til acoide también tenemos por aquí a la
membrana del tee la coidh pero conforme
ese electrón va pasando de molécula en
molécula
bajando su nivel de energía suceden dos
cosas una es que esta energía que va
perdiendo el electrón se utiliza para
bombear protones de hidrógeno a través
de la membrana del sil acoide y luego
cuando hay una gran concentración de
protones de hidrógeno éstos pasan por
aquí por la atp si interesa dándole
energía
para que se puedan crear moléculas de
atp y luego el aceptar final de ese
electrón o también lo podemos ver como
el aceptar de hidrógeno depende de cómo
lo quieras ver el punto es que un átomo
completo de hidrógeno es aceptado por
una molécula dna de temas así es que los
dos productos o bueno los dos productos
que vamos a seguir utilizando en la
fotosíntesis que también lo escribí por
aquí los dos productos de la fase
luminosa que vamos a seguir utilizando
son las moléculas de atp y de ndp h y
también obtenemos otro subproducto
porque necesitamos reemplazar ese
electrón excitado así es que le quitamos
un electrón a una molécula de agua y de
esa forma además obtenemos oxígeno que
es un subproducto muy valioso pero bueno
ahora ya que producimos atp y n
bp h ya estamos listos para ir a la fase
oscura y repito nuevamente que aunque
esta se llame la fase oscura sucede
durante el día de hecho sucede al mismo
tiempo que está sucediendo la fase
luminosa y ocurre también cuando el sol
está brillando afuera aunque también
puede ocurrir cuando es de noche ahora
la razón por la que decimos que es una
fase oscura es porque las reacciones son
independientes de la luz porque no
requieren de fotones para ocurrir
únicamente necesitan atp ndp h y dióxido
de carbono así es que ahora vamos a ver
con un poco más de profundidad esto de
las reacciones de la fase oscura pero lo
vamos a ver en un lugar con más espacio
por aquí así es que tenemos nuestras
reacciones dependientes de la luz
y como acabamos de repasar las
producen atp atp y ndp h n a dp h y
ahora vamos a tomar un poco de dióxido
de carbono del medio ambiente todo esto
junto al dióxido de carbono con el atp
con el n a dp h todo esto entra a las
reacciones independientes de la luz ok
lo voy a seguir llamando reacciones
independientes de la luz en lugar de
reacciones de la fase oscura porque este
nombre crea mucha confusión así es que
todo esto entra a las reacciones
independientes de la luz
acciones independientes de la luz y
bueno tal cual el mecanismo se llama el
ciclo de kelvin que es de lo que se
trata este vídeo así es que todo esto
entra al ciclo de calvin y de él sale le
podemos llamar pegar o también lo
podemos llamar g3 p pero estas dos son
simplemente diferentes formas de
llamarle a la misma molécula fósforo y
literal de ido o literal de ido tres
post facto y bueno es un poco más
complicado que esto pero nos lo podemos
imaginar como tres carbonos en una
cadena con un grupo fosfato pero repito
es una molécula un poquito más
complicada que ésta y luego ésta puede
ser utilizada para formar otros
carbohidratos si ponemos dos de estas
juntas podemos obtener una glucosa
incluso puede ser que te acuerdes que en
la primera fase de la glucólisis o bueno
cuando partimos de la glucosa en dos
pedazos lo que obtuvimos fueron dos
moléculas de fósforo glicerol de ido o
sea dos de estas moléculas la glucosa
tiene seis carga
y cada uno de estos fósforo glitter
aldehídos tiene tres carbonos pero bueno
ahora vamos a estudiar el ciclo de
calvin por aquí vamos a empezar el ciclo
de calvin con 6 dióxido de carbono y más
adelante voy a explicar por qué estoy
escogiendo es el número de dióxido de
carbono pero por el momento empezamos
con 6 dióxido de carbono y además voy a
escribir por aquí un ace del carbono
porque aquí lo que realmente nos importa
son los carbonos y la cantidad de
carbonos pero bueno estos 6 dióxido de
carbono reaccionan con otras 6 moléculas
que pronto voy a hablar acerca de estas
reacciones pero estas son seis moléculas
que podemos abreviar como rubén y su
nombre original es rigurosa 1.5 y
fosfato o simplemente rívolo xavi
fosfato y la
son por la que se llama así es porque es
una cadena de 5 carbonos y tiene un
grupo fosfato en los carbonos 1 y 5
aunque bueno aquí también esta cadena de
5 carbonos es un poquito más complicada
de lo que lo estamos dibujando así es
que esta molécula se llama rigurosa por
esta cadena de 5 carbonos y luego en el
carbono 1 tiene un grupo fosfato y en el
carbono 5 tiene otro grupo fosfato por
lo cual tiene dos grupos fosfatos y de
ahí sale la parte débil fosfato así es
que aquí tenemos a la rigurosa 15 de
fosfato que suena como un nombre muy
complicado pero en realidad es
simplemente una molécula con 5 carbonos
y dos grupos dos patos
así es que estas moléculas reaccionan y
esto es una sobre simplificación pero
primero quiero que veas la imagen
general estas moléculas reaccionan para
formar dos moléculas de fósforo glitter
aldehído o también los podemos llamar
literal
y 23 fosfatos que ahí tenemos 12
moléculas de gas y estas moléculas las
podemos ver como una cadena de 3
carbonos con un grupo fosfato pero
repito estas cadenas son un poquito más
complicadas de lo que las estamos
dibujando y ahora sólo para asegurarnos
que tenemos la cantidad correcta de
carbonos pues vamos a contarlos por aquí
tenemos 12 de estas moléculas y estas
moléculas tienen 3 carbonos entonces 3
por 12 36 aquí tenemos 36 carbonos así
es que nos hacemos la pregunta de si
empezamos con 36 carbonos bueno pues
aquí tenemos 6 moléculas que tienen 5
carbonos cada una 6 por 5 30 y empezamos
con 6 moléculas de dióxido de carbono y
cada una de ellas tiene un carbono así
es que si por aquí empezamos con 36
carbonos y obtenemos estas dos moléculas
pegas ahora una cosa importante también
es que los enlaces
no los electrones de estas moléculas
están en un mayor nivel de energía que
en los reactivos entonces para que se dé
esta reacción necesitamos ponerle
energía esto no va a suceder de forma
espontánea y la energía necesaria para
que se dé esta reacción la obtenemos si
aquí tenemos 6 dióxido de carbono y 6
rubén pérez necesitamos 12 moléculas de
atp de hecho lo podemos ver como que son
dos moléculas de atp por cada molécula
de dióxido de carbono y una molécula de
rigurosa vy fosfato y también
necesitamos aquí otras 12 moléculas de
ndp h y luego estas se transforman en 12
moléculas de adt y 12 grupos fosfato y
también en 12 moléculas de ndp más y la
razón por la que esta es una fuente de
energía es porque el electrón en esta
molécula o bueno el hidrógeno y su
electrón están en un nivel de energía
más alto
así es que cuando bajan de nivel de
energía ayudan a que suceda alguna
reacción y sucede lo mismo con las
moléculas de atp aquí los electrones
tienen un alto nivel de energía pero
cuando pierden a un grupo fosfato entran
a un nivel más bajo de energía y esta
energía puede ayudar a que suceda esta
reacción así es que tenemos 12 moléculas
pegar y ahora la razón por la que esto
se llama el ciclo de calvin sobre todo
la parte de ciclo es porque esto es un
ciclo y hemos visto esto también en el
ciclo de krebs los ciclos reutilizan a
sus moléculas y la razón por la que esto
se llama el ciclo de calvin es porque
aquí también vamos a reutilizar a
nuestras moléculas de hecho vamos a
reutilizar casi todas estas moléculas
pegar así es que vamos a reutilizar la
mayoría de estas moléculas pegar lo que
hay de hecho vamos a reutilizar
gales 10 de éstos pegar los vamos a
reutilizar para volver a construir las 6
moléculas de rigurosa be fosfato y si
contamos los carbonos nos da la cuenta
exacta porque 10 por 3 son 36 por 5
también son 30 pero nuevamente esto
necesita energía para suceder así es que
vamos a necesitar 6 atp
y vamos a obtener 6 a de p
y cuatro grupos fosfato ok porque aquí
estos ataques no sólo nos proporcionan
la energía para que suceda esta reacción
sino que además aportan fosfatos que
necesitan los rigurosos be fosfatos que
no pueden proporcionar las moléculas
pegan de hecho estos cuatro grupos
fosfato no provienen de las moléculas de
atp sino de las moléculas pegan y los
grupos fosfato de los atp es a la hora
de convertirse en la dps se quedan en
las moléculas rebull o xavi fosfato si
es que como podemos ver esto es un ciclo
y luego aquí nos podemos preguntar oye
pero de qué me sirve estar haciendo
estos ciclos y bueno pues sí aquí
estamos reutilizando 10 moléculas pegar
pero nos quedamos con otras dos
moléculas pegar aunque hoy utilizamos 10
de los pegas para reconstruir a la rival
o xavi fosfato y nosotros nos quedamos
con dos de esas moléculas penal y si
tenemos dos de estas moléculas pegas
entonces podemos tener una molécula de
glucosa y esa es la razón por la que
escogí que tuviéramos aquí 6 moléculas
de dióxido de carbono y 6 moléculas de
régulo xavi fosfato porque de esa forma
obtenemos 12 moléculas pegar y entonces
con cada ciclo nos quedamos con dos
moléculas pegar con las cuales se puede
formar una glucosa la glucosa es un
carbohidrato de 6 carbonos conocemos su
fórmula es de 6 h
pero otra cosa que también es muy
importante recordar es que aquí con las
moléculas de pegar no necesariamente
tenemos que crear glucosa podemos crear
cadenas de carbohidratos muchísimo más
largas que podemos crear almidón podemos
crear cualquier cadena que tenga una
columna de carbonos y ya lo tenemos
estas son las reacciones de la fase
oscura
las reacciones independientes de la luz
por aquí tomamos los productos de la
fase luminosa todos estos atp y nh y
utilizamos esa energía para fijar al
carbono esto que estamos haciendo aquí
es lo que se llama la fijación del
carbono cuando tomamos el carbono en su
forma gaseosa y lo ponemos en una
estructura sólida así es que a través de
este ciclo de calvin logramos fijar al
carbono utilizando esta energía que
generamos en la fase luminosa y por
supuesto le llamamos ciclo porque
producimos todas estas moléculas pegar
las cuales solo poquitas las podemos
utilizar para crear glucosa o algunos
otros compuestos pero la mayoría de
estas moléculas que producimos las
reutilizamos para construir nuevamente
rebull o xavi fosfato para poder volver
a empezar el ciclo lo que ya está rívolo
xabi fosfato vuelve a reaccionar con el
dióxido de carbono formando otras 12
moléculas pegan de las cuales 2 se
pueden volver a utilizar para formar
glucosa y otras 10 se regresan para
volver a empezar el ciclo ahora esto
claramente no sucede en el vacío si nos
interesa saber donde sucede el ciclo de
calvin nos tenemos que regresar por acá
el ciclo de calvin sucede en el estroma
yo creo que es el líquido adentro del
cloroplasto pero afuera del til acoide
ok aquí en el estroma es donde suceden
todas las reacciones de la fase oscura
las reacciones independientes de la luz
pero además no necesitan únicamente la
fuente de energía atp y ndp h de hecho
también necesitan una enzima que tiene
un tamaño bastante grande está esta
enzima o proteína que facilita que
sucedan estas reacciones aunque hay que
facilita que reaccionen el dióxido de
carbono y la rívolo xavi fosfato y que
colocan estas moléculas en el lugar
adecuado para que se puedan dar estas
reacciones y esta enzima la tenemos
dibujada por aquí se llama rubisco
rubisco la abreviación de rigurosa de
fosfato carboxilasa oxigena za y es esta
proteína enzima gigantesca que estamos
viendo por aquí en la cual se puede
enlazar larry bull o xavi fosfato
en algún lugar y las moléculas de
dióxido de carbono también se pueden
enlazar en algún otro lugar de esta
enzima la verdad no sé muy bien en qué
partes de la enzima se enlazan pero ya
que están enlazadas con la ayuda de la
energía del atp y el ndp h esta enzima
se puede doblar se puede modificar y
provoca que el dióxido de carbono y la
rigurosa vy fosfato reaccionen
facilitando que suceda el ciclo de
calvin y listo ya terminamos con la
fotosíntesis
en la fotosíntesis logramos empezar con
fotones y agua y producir atp
nh porque teníamos estos electrones que
se existen y tenemos todo este mecanismo
de quimio smodis que permite que la atp
sin tasa produzca atp y también
producimos ndp h porque n además es el
aceptar final de electrones y usamos
esto como energía para que suceda el
ciclo de calvin en la fase oscura que
nuevamente repito fase oscura es un muy
mal nombre porque sucede cuando hay luz
por lo que es mejor llamarle fase
independiente de la luz así es que en
esta fase independiente de la luz
tomamos los productos de la fase
luminosa que nos dan energía junto con
dióxido de carbono y podemos fijarlo
utilizando nuestra enzima rubisco y
terminamos con nuestro fósforo y literal
de ido aunque con el pedal que también
se le puede llamar glee será leído 3
fosfatos
o sea que 3 p que después se puede
utilizar para formar glucosa que es algo
que todos nosotros seres vivos realmente
utilizamos para comer y para darle
energía a nuestros cuerpos
ok porque como aprendimos en la
respiración celular la glucosa se puede
utilizar para crear moléculas de atp
cuando las necesitemos